let's get one more and
I don't identify with models the ideal
Abercrombie & Fitch model is definitely
probably white hot I mean I've never
seen a trans guy model anything
professionally I never see Indians I
have no boobs I'm wondering like if this
will make me feel more beautiful or like
more wanted
daddy cashew it's hot as hell right now
yeah I am I do not smell good my feet
stink I do not think this is realistic
no there's definitely some computers
going on with this stuff my knees part
right now so yeah it'll be interesting
to see like myself in that position that
I never really connected with gay
marinate movement body
it was good so it's interesting just
kind of like being naked and like
there's just like people walking around
but at the same time like it starts to
get empowering after a while like it's
okay like you can see like my scars and
stuff but I kind of like that because
it's like yeah like we all have scars I
like that word stuff because I like
character it feels real ya know we place
so much emphasis on the naked body you
want to sleep at the end of the day it's
just skin I'm a little uncomfortable but
I'm also strangely comfortable in a room
full of strangers on the Internet
in my underwear as a [ __ ] man
modeling Calvin Klein underwear I think
that's a first maybe for the world
yeah I feel good that's the very gram
it's fun a company will choose a white
woman over a woman of colored so I think
the only way to start to change that is
by just feeding people of color instead
of white faces so that we're more
comfortable in society with people of
color
my dad is Indian and my mom is white
growing up kids would tell me that I was
adopted now that I'm older it has so
much more confident in my skin and this
experience really allowed me to embrace
my skin color
I'm excited I think it's gonna be good
I just I feel like a big old dork
I'm excited I'm a little nervous I'm not
gonna lie we were sweaty that day they
ready like we look so hot they're
gorgeous and amazing but so are we
Wow Wow it's funny because I feel like
this photo makes me look like I'm just
calm and lying on a bed when in reality
I was breaking my back drooling all over
my hand what you see is this one single
moment when in reality it was something
else the first thing I noticed that was
like strikingly different was hair for
me that's not my ideal standard of
beauty that dress is not really a dress
I would wear and because it's an ad it
doesn't really make me feel any more
beautiful I kind of prefer the way I
look on a regular day
look hot my back rolls are definitely
there he doesn't have any back girls he
has dimples even though it is me it's
nice to see somebody that's like
everyday and looks like me in an ad
alright but I look better than I thought
I would honestly it would be cool if
there was a trans guy in an actual
Calvin Klein ad expectedly I look at
fashion ads I often compare myself to
them and feel bad looking at them but I
have to remember that I never get
professional hair and makeup done and
all of those people do and they also
have Photoshop on their side you know
there shouldn't be one perfect type of
body I think that we should be able to
live in a world where both images can
exist and we're not fighting for one to
be the best they're just all there
Wow